à chaque rentrée scolaire c'est le même
problème des cartables trop lourds pour
les écoliers des deux courbes et par le
poids des livres
un constat effectué dès les années 60
transports à l'époque les devoirs à la
maison sont interdits en vertu d'une
circulaire ministérielle de 1956
pourtant elle n'est pas appliquée par
toutes les écoles résultat les élèves
ramène trop de livres scolaires chez eux
c'est trop lourd oui oui oui ça fait
lourd et qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
à votre avis écoutez j'ai pas et on
devrait les laisser prendre juste un
livre y laisser les autres à l'école les
rentrées s'enchaînent et le problème
persiste notamment au collège avec une
multitude de cours différents les élèves
se retrouvent parfois à porter des sacs
pouvant peser jusqu'à 10 kg alors
stéphanie dites-moi conséquences des
problèmes de dos pour les élèves
bien souvent des enfants nous viennent
avec une dispense d'éducation physique
de la peur d'un médecin et il ya
énormément de scoliose
en 1995 le poids du cartable devient une
question de santé publique
il ne doit pas dépasser 10% du poids
total de l'élève selon une note
ministérielle
alors que faire pour alléger les sacs
les casiers sont parfois mis à
disposition des élèves
du côté des éditeurs de livres une
solution est trouvée en 2003 cette année
là les manuels ont perdu 30 % de leur
poids
on est passé de pages qui était de 90
grammes au mètre carré à des pages 70 g
m² et on a changé les couvertures qui
sont devenus des couvertures souples
intégra dans les années 2000
d'autres alternatives sont proposées à
l'image du sac à dos à roulettes des
livres scolaires distribué en double
exemplaire ou encore du cartable
électronique
pourtant malgré ces innovations c'est
toujours le même souci les cartables
sont trop lourds comme ici en 2013
ça pèse dans les viiie régulièrement
alors qu'on a pris le sac lé plus léger
à la base pour éviter justement qu'il
n'est trop emporté avec la rentrée
scolaire
la question du sac surchargé devrait
encore se poser pourtant chaque année
des pesées sont faites à l'entrée des
établissements scolaires
en 2019 selon la fcpe la plupart des
cartables de collégiens peser plus de 17
% de leur poids
[Musique]